tengo seis números aquí y puedes ver que
cinco de ellos son irracionales pues
tienen involucrado la raíz cuadrada de
un número que no es un cuadrado perfecto
y en esta ocasión nuestro objetivo será
ordenar del menor al mayor sin
calculadora y es buen momento para que
pausa este vídeo y veas si puedes
hacerlo ahora bien te voy a dar una
pista la pista es que es muy difícil si
no usar calculadora sacar estas raíces
la raíz de 2 es 1 punto algo algo algo y
la raíz de 3 1 punto algo algo como
podemos resolver este problema de lo que
quiero que te des cuenta es que si
tenemos un número a mayor que 0 es decir
un número positivo y sabemos que a es
menor que de entonces va a ser bastante
bueno saber que a cuadrada a cuadrada es
menor que b cuadrado es decir si un
número positivo es menor que otro número
positivo entonces el 4
el primero será menor que el cuadrado
del segundo así que una cosa que podemos
hacer para resolver este problema de
comparar números racionales que
involucren raíces cuadradas de números
que no son cuadrados perfectos es
comparar estos cuadrados porque sus
cuadrados van a hacer números que no son
irracionales y así será muy fácil
compararlos y después ordenarlos porque
si ordenamos los cuadrados vamos a poder
ordenar las raíces cuadradas así que de
qué estamos hablando vamos a elevar al
cuadrado cada uno de estos así que
empecemos con este que tenemos aquí
bueno pues el primero es 4 raíz de 2 así
que si a éste lo elevamos al cuadrado
esto va a ser exactamente lo mismo que
tomarme cuatro veces la raíz de 2 que
bueno multiplica que multiplica vamos a
ponerlo así a cuatro veces la raíz de 2
si nosotros cambiamos un poco el orden
de estos productos esto lo puedo ver
exactamente igual que tomarme 4x4 bueno
esto multiplicado por la raíz de 2 que a
su vez multiplica a la raíz de dos dicho
de otra manera lo único que hice fue
cambiar el orden de los productos y
bueno en este caso tengo 4 por 4 lo cual
es 16 y aquí tengo raíz de 2 x raíz de 2
y bueno recuerda que esto es exactamente
lo mismo que la raíz de 2 al cuadrado lo
cual es 216 por 2 y bueno esto es lo
mismo que 32 así que el cuadrado de
cuatro veces la raíz de dos es 32 y
vamos a hacer el siguiente bueno si lo
hacemos un poco más rápido este al
cuadrado que me va a quedar a dejan
cambiar de color al color amarillo este
si lo elevamos al cuadrado me va a
quedar a dos veces la raíz de 3 esto
a 2 al cuadrado y cuántos esto bueno
pues esto es lo mismo que tomarme 2
elevado al cuadrado que multiplica a la
raíz de tres elevado al cuadrado a la
raíz de 3 elevada al cuadrado es decir
estoy elevando cada uno de estos dos
números al cuadrado y multiplicando los
entre sí y todos elevado al cuadrado es
4 por la raíz de 3 elevado al cuadrado
lo cual es 3 entonces 4 por 3 es lo
mismo que 12 12 es el cuadrado de 2
veces la raíz de 3 y si este paso se te
hizo un poco complicado recuerda que si
tenemos el producto de dos cosas que
están elevadas al cuadrado esto es lo
mismo que elevar cada uno de los
productos al cuadrado y después tomar el
producto tomar la multiplicación y te
puedes dar cuenta que algo similar hice
aquí lo cual da mucho sentido a esto que
tenemos escrito y bueno si esto lo
podemos ver de una manera más sencilla
entonces podría trabajar con este de
aquí el cuadrado de este va a ser
exactamente lo mismo que tomarme 3
elevado al cuadrado lo cual
es 9 por la raíz de 2 elevada al
cuadrado
la raíz de 2 elevada al cuadrado es lo
mismo que 2 y 9 por 2 es 18 así que 18
es el cuadrado de este que tenemos aquí
en este caso tenemos la raíz de 17 y si
a esta la elevamos al cuadrado bueno
pues eso es muy sencillo me va a quedar
simple y sencillamente 1717 y bueno por
aquí tengo tres veces la raíz de tres a
esto lo voy a elevar al cuadrado y de la
misma manera 3 elevado al cuadrado es 9
por la raíz de 3 elevado al cuadrado la
raíz de 3 elevada al cuadrado estrés o
dicho otra manera 9 por 3 es 27 27 es el
cuadrado de 3 veces la raíz de 3 y bueno
para acabar tengo al 55 elevado al
cuadrado es muy sencillo eso lo sabemos
5 elevado al cuadrado es 25 bueno pues
es hora de ordenar los de menor a mayor
así que entre 32
18 17 27 y 25 cuales el menor bueno pues
el menor sin dudarlo es 12 12 es el
menor de todos estos cuadrados y por lo
tanto dos veces la raíz de 3 es el menor
de todos estos números que tenemos aquí
por lo tanto lo voy a poner en un inicio
el primero el menor es dos veces la raíz
de tres entonces a éste ya lo tenemos
cubierto quien sigue bueno entre todos
estos sigue el 17 el 17 es el que sigue
de menor a mayor y por lo tanto la raíz
de 17 es el que va a seguir después de
dos veces la raíz de tres así que lo voy
a poner aquí la raíz de 17 y ya tenemos
cubierto a este después sigue en 1818
éste viene de tres veces la raíz de dos
elevado al cuadrado y por lo tanto este
va a ser el número que sigue a
continuación tres veces la raíz de 2
tres veces la raíz de dos date cuenta de
cómo estoy observando los cuadrados para
así obtener el orden en cada uno de
estos números después seguiría el 25 y
bueno en 25 lo obtuvimos elevar 5 al
cuadrado así que voy a poner aquí 5 esto
está muy sencillo y este ya está y
después siguen el 27 solamente me falta
el 27 y el 32 y entre ellos dos el 27 es
más pequeño que salió de elevar 3 raíz
de 3 al cuadrado así que lo voy a poner
aquí tres veces la raíz de tres y bueno
entonces el más grande de todos ellos
fue 32 32 salió de elevar cuatro veces
la raíz de dos al cuadrado por lo tanto
este es el más grande de todos ellos es
un mayor y eso es todo lo hemos logrado
estuvo bastante bien pues sin
calculadora logramos ordenar estos
números irracionales excepto el 5
recuerdan que tenían involucrada una
raíz cuadrada de 1
número que no es un cuadrado perfecto